these giant corporations vote Democrat
why because they want government
favoritism
just remember this Amazon Apple Google
Facebook Microsoft there is your
argument which party do you think is the
party of corrupt big business cronyism
do you think it's portrayed accurately
by the media because this is one thing
I've seen a lot energize me crazy and it
is remarkable to me and I will I will
debunk this hopefully with just five
words immediately after this clip
everyone accepts this myth big business
there the pot there they are Republicans
are the party of big business crony
capitalists here you go don't hear my
word for it
when will you centrist realize if you
play the corporate money always to was a
tablecloth big business you out
corporate you no matter how much blood
money you take or how far to the right
you run we are going to put pro-worker
appointees on the NLRB not Stooges but
big business because business owners
don't work apparently
so listen yeah it's true most business
owners lean right yours truly gen organ
junior but that's because the vast
majority of businesses are small to
mid-size and by the way when I say small
to midsize I'm talking about well into
the tens of millions of dollars not
saying twenty employees you would be in
a tens of millions of action there are
plenty of businesses yeah twenty but
we're comparing this to the big
billionaire right businesses so it's
true listen the big billionaire business
has billiad multi-billion dollar
conglomerates yeah crony as' got it but
Republicans alright five works for you
what's the top five companies by market
value Apple Amazon Google Facebook
Microsoft let me give it let me give you
that again hmm
Apple Amazon Google Facebook Microsoft
sorry Google is alphabet which has both
Google and YouTube with a change much
when you think of those do you think of
a bastion of right-wing conservatism no
these are by far the biggest businesses
in the world right now so let's look at
specific partisan policies that these
companies have actually supported let's
go to Apple first most platforms that
we've talked to this most platforms will
get to Facebook and YouTube they claim
to be neutral app Apple doesn't they're
positively post I don't know hey Tim
Cook read an Aesop fable here you go
pastor
banning its boast yeah that's the first
time I heard see the CEO Tim Cook okay
bragged about banning Alex Jones after
do platforming of saying that their
values were dictated or at least
dictated what they would even allow for
example in their app store here you go
at Apple we are not afraid to say that
our values drive our curation decisions
and why should we be quiet
I can't think of a good reason why we're
going to get to at the end of the
political contributions and the macro
policies that all of these companies
support I want to get to the individual
sort of I guess causes of these people
the ones close to their heart because
he's not afraid not afraid he's not
afraid to speak out we got cheer to that
cook I am glad that you are a dance for
us Jeff Bezos Amazon mostly human
Democrats case supported litany of their
causes surprised and for those who don't
vote out spoken critic of Trump okay
saying that what listen we here you go
listen it is a mistake for any elected
official in my opinion I don't think
this is a very out-there opinion to
attack media and journalists what the
president should say is I love how he
just this is White's immediate deserve
good I'm glad and being scrutinized and
that would be so secure and confident
again remember Apple Amazon Google
Facebook Microsoft Apple Amazon Google
Facebook Microsoft so anytime someone
tells you a big Republican to the party
a big business Apple Amazon Facebook
Google Microsoft Amazon I guarantee you
that one probably market capital in
trillion let's move on to alphabet
Google okay we know obviously that they
censorship they think they employ
censorship of conservatives they think
about Google is they couldn't be less
politically diverse if they attempted it
so for those who don't recall obvious
remember James do more the he was fired
for question the far left policies but
here's what I love even more than that
so you would say well maybe that's a
one-off alright next clip we're gonna
get to is after Trump was elected Google
alphabet sorry held them this massive
did you receive he you've never seen
this video the company wide a massive
company while a therapy session I want
to see a yeah okay I'll just go to Ellen
yeah I'll face it most
smiling you're better care our homeless
in this country pretty upset I'm pretty
sad moving on is because of the election
the values that are held dear at this
company transcend politics because we're
going to constantly that's another way
of saying I'm lying to you couple are
leaving exactly staff is crying we're
gonna lose how was the first moment I
really felt I'm gonna lose it was this
massive like kick in the gut okay sorry
I got excited thank you I mean probably
past menopause here's the thing do you
notice something else that people before
where they were talking about journalism
and media they equated it down do you
hear what she just said I think a lot of
people miss that she said I realized
that we were going to lose whoa yeah are
you Chelsea Clinton's the head of goo
what's happening here we were going to
lose it assumes that every single person
at Google at alphabet at YouTube
subsequently agree with her we and when
you look at their party you look at who
they fired like James Tamar you look at
the memos that circulate it is it really
is absolutely a political monolith
that's why I say this is above politics
it's not about left versus right it's
about right versus wrong really you held
the best therapy because the guy who is
not we meaning any Republican one right
listen we understand it's fine to
outright of course ban violence although
they don't really do this in a lot of
social media platforms but YouTube
they've gone as far they've labeled a
lot of right-wing content as violations
of Terms of Service and it's not just
shadow banning they actually they have
this new term on the border content
we've talked about this but again for
people who don't understand the politics
of Amazon Apple Google Facebook
Microsoft here you go so content that
violates our guidelines are hate speech
guidelines which prohibit anything that
that's broad enough but she gets even
broader here against individuals or
groups that's the most third most
powerful car in the world oh it's hatred
against individuals or groups based on
their characteristics including race
gender ethnicity religion all of that
content is a violative of our Community
Guidelines okay it's content that's on
the border is content that we no longer
include in our recommendation algorithm
and it
also be demonetised and comments are
disabled etcetera so we do our best to
ensure that content that is on the
border isn't isn't fully distributed aha
it's like before you were talking about
your violation it's like saying yeah we
know that murder is we have made murder
a crime okay understood right also all
the other actions how do we define those
would they are so we have of course
murder over here right yeah and then
under this umbrella all of the other
ones may be banned both equally we ban
all the other ones yeah
she says explicitly border on the border
which the first I thought I was like a
commercial for salsa border they'll do
monetize it they'll take it out of
suggested video right yeah which isn't
yeah that's big right because if your if
your means of income is to put YouTube
videos out there you need it to be in
suggested videos you need my use you
need is dollars this is exact how else
do you get people to view your video you
can't and by the way how do they become
one of the most what not profitable one
of the most worthy one of the most
valuable companies in the world yeah by
people creating content for their yes
exactly so that is when we talk about
workers rights and revolutions and
season the means of production what I'm
talking about but I am saying a
dishonest business practice when you say
please upload to our platform here and
it's gone yeah well that was it was one
of all of the other things in other ways
they've done this to change my mind yeah
okay we're not dealing with their Terms
of Service here I don't understand this
this is I don't want to be self
gratifying here no if you were going to
ban and D monetize or D monetize at
least change my mind
I don't what could possibly be
acceptable yeah right wing content I
mean granted it's not 12 year olds or 8
year olds and drag queen [ __ ] makeup
tutorials I understand that this is
material right yeah it's not quite a
four-year-old singing happy birthday mr.
president like Marilyn Monroe above some
kind of a sure great was it blowing up
if I get it I get it you want fun for
the whole family
free to understand that it's first we
have rape Oh g-god mmm rape but then you
have everything you just said oh man
rape are bad and all the words you used
margarita time but on the border
order Microsoft of course we got listen
Bill Gates of course we know Bill Gates
one of the he was the wealthiest person
in the world oh yeah
now besos thinks it's cute but we are at
the point here where he doesn't really
champion the free market that brought
him to that point he's been pretty
critical of it he's even supported
far-left causes like carbon taxes which
we'll get to why would a business
support that if you think it would harm
businesses well again this is why the
big companies almost always support
policies that hurt midsize and small
companies Bill Gates in his wife long
history by the way of supporting causes
like population control the abortion
exams of China yeah well his dad served
on the board of Planned Parenthood I
think yeah I think we the issue that
really grabbed me as as urgent was were
issues related to population
reproductive health when I was growing
up my parents were always involved in
Barry's volunteer things my dad was had
a Planned Parenthood and loved killing
it was very controversial to be involved
with that
think of that for a second the richest
most powerful man in the world's father
was head of Planned Parenthood yeah if
that's not terrifying what kind of
leftist by the way yeah after Trump cut
you know the Mexico City policy was Bush
and save then it was reversed by Barack
Obama so that we wouldn't be funding
abortion overseas and the reversal was
reversed by Donald Trump I know this is
kind of nerdy policy wonkish the point
is the Gates is I think it's a say at
the gates is is the gates is if Lander
is is this network they were surrounded
by giving three hundred and seventy five
million dollars that's to abortion
providing organizations oh my god three
hundred and seventy five million dollars
to the services of killing babies you
say tomato I say get the forceps Amazon
Apple Facebook Google might yourself
Damon's on Apple Facebook Google
Microsoft thank Tim someone says big
mostest let's go to Facebook of course
more censorship of the right we've known
this is 2016 Facebook there was this big
Gizmodo article where I found out my
page was beating throttle oops imagine
mice I was reading a list okay Ted Cruz
are right Breitbart and Chris Kyle
Foundation ah I know that guy one of
these things
it's not like the other ones running for
president one goes undercover as a
[ __ ] I don't know anyway this has been
going on for at Furyk it's been going on
for years in essence at least it was
revealed in 2016
here's how you know that it's severe
Zuckerberg when he was asked couldn't
name a single figure from the left who
was banned from the question let me ask
this now [ __ ] are you aware of any ad or
page that has been taken down from
Planned Parenthood senator but let me
just move on another luck oh sorry
how about moveon.org I'm not
specifically aware of this how about any
Democratic candidate for office I'm not
specifically aware i mean i i'm not i'm
not sure i'm someone get tim cook he's
not afraid to speak out they should
decide whether they're a publisher or
whether they're a platform yeah Apple
Amazon Facebook Google Microsoft I know
the order might have switched but I'm
going back wrote what about Big Oil what
about the Koch brothers is what a lot of
people talk about again this is this is
sort of the slate of him look look at
what's going on the left hand and in
this one you know I'm fondling you
that's what happens most missions that
Joe Biden no be our present org job I
could be anybody namely it was it was
the great the great Mandy was his name
yeah so in the Montreal yeah you know I
let father change man okay yeah there's
also a priest so they rail against Big
Oil all the time I think way the clip
right of getting Big Oil money getting
these corporate money corporate money's
out of politics see I just fixed if I
send you money to it yeah so there's
nothing stopping me from being entirely
funded by corporate packs say from the
fossil fuel industry the healthcare
industry Big Pharma I'm entirely
hundred-percent you say the lobbyists
PAC funded it is imperative the
corporation's not be allowed to give
money to politicians or to assist them
in any way to say I'm flattered that is
the most important rule and law that we
need in this country okay let this
really quickly top 10 oil companies in
the entire United States industry like
Exxon Mobil Chevron all the big
boogeyman yeah don't even crack one
trillion in value okay combine
comparable companies have just gone
through again can you say it with me
Apple Amazon Google Facebook Microsoft
four trillion a bailout five
companies Google Facebook Amazon Apple
Microsoft IMS any Amazon's but I think
yeah they're worth four times just five
companies worth four times the entire
United States oil industry Wow what do
you think that where do their campaign
campaign donations go 90% we know
roughly from Google they give to
Democrats and by the way you can look at
this across the board some people say
well they give to both well so does Wall
Street Wall Street is pretty sibling a
lot of these companies are split because
they're just hedging their bets they
don't want to give to both that's why
it's important to look at their
individual policies look at their
individual viewpoints certainly the CEOs
and then look at the totality of the
donations most of which still go to
Democrats overwhelmingly and this is
something else that I think a lot of
people miss well these businesses all
then they support things like net
neutrality they support intrusive
government policies like carbon tax
interesting right over I get all kinds
of red tape why it begs the question you
have five top five companies they
weren't created in some kind of a
leftist petri dish now how do they all
agree on these policies well for the
exact opposite reason that mid tier and
small business owners overwhelmingly
vote against those policies so small
business owners a middle bit the middle
sized business owners they
overwhelmingly vote Republican because
they want an even playing field yes they
want to be able to run a business and
make sure that nobody's getting an
unfair advantage whereas these giant
corporations vote Democrat why because
they want government favoritism that's
the important factor here when you look
at a huge divide between all businesses
and in the top five it does beg the
question why look at these these far
left companies these huge companies
where they support these leftist causes
well for the same reason that the giant
banks support a big bank bailouts worth
when you look at it the smaller banks
and the middle tier banks Wow still
millions upon millions of dollars in
these banks didn't support it why
because the big banks no of course where
you look at all these government
regulations that have to drop in the
bucket for them but it could be
absolutely it could be crushing yeah to
these middle sized businesses to these
small sized businesses they won't be
able to burden these costs someone like
Google someone like Bill Gates says hey
I can pay the carbon tax you know who
can't it's a business it's only worth 40
or 50 million dollars the upstart
software company that's crippled their
ability so I'm going to play ball with
the government this is important for
people to note and it doesn't matter
this is what I've always talked I'm not
a I'm not a guy who cares about big
business versus small
versus middle business because guess
what I keep saying middle I mean to say
middle here mid tier is middle business
I only care about good business because
if you have an even playing field it
doesn't matter the size of your business
what matters is that you're playing the
game honestly yeah what matters I don't
care if you go out sell your wares
whatever you want to do as long as you
are not doing so at the taxpayers
expense suckling at the government teat
Tesla and it's really important to me
for everyone to know this is one of
those truisms that just isn't true well
Republicans are the party of big
business well we could also do a whole
segment on Wall Street but we don't need
to just remember this Amazon Apple
Google Facebook Microsoft there is your
argument video this is the part where I
would usually tell you to subscribe but
I can't do it anymore I'm gonna tell you
to subscribe and then YouTube is going
to decide that we can't reach you even
though you subscribe to this channel and
then I'll say hit the notification bell
and then the notification bell won't
even be there anymore I don't know what
to say more than likely you'll find my
face in a milk carton but do what you
can to stop it it's just that it's just
it probably won't do much